[Music]
line of light in life my life I can
choose one of them
no I did this my wife's right behind
what's the biggest library that a guy
that I really like to feel in love with
me when I was 14 but it's ruse but
totally wrong I would tell everyone
every single one I have a had any beers
tonight that I was continuing college
behind my parents back they got a nice
call from a professor saying you know
your daughter hasn't been in class for a
few weeks
well
how BIG's his film project where's he
gonna go pretty pretends to be a
football or soccer player yeah I think
when I was younger I used to tell people
that I lost my virginity when I was 13
and I was really like 15 when I lost it
but I think when you're that young my
boyfriend's were not virgins and I was
like either
that I didn't fall off a building when I
fell off a building well I mean you an
ironworker so you know we're way up
there like stories and stories and
stories and one time I fell off a
building for the third floor to the
ground and nobody saw me but one dude
and then everybody asked did you just
fall in I was like you know and then
that dude told my bosses like yeah I
watched it fall I bet you felt that I
don't lie how much money I had my bank
account you don't have very much you
know seem as important or well-off I
guess when I I was younger think of
money to the my mother's mother take off
money off my mother when I was little
probably I almost drowned in a pool
while my sister was watching me and she
told me to never tell my mother and so
I basically did just die I never told
her I said everything was fine and I was
like traumatized that day but I got over
it biggest lie I've ever told is that
man when I was a little kid I told my
cousin I never stole any of his toys but
every time I went over to his house I
always put him in my pocket tell him I
was feeling sick and I'd go home and
play with his toys okay I told my
boyfriend that I'm a virgin it would
probably be cheating on somebody I was I
was a little girl and I told my father
that I had lost is hammer but by the way
we broke it who is my brother and we
hide it behind the workbench and we find
it again at probably 25 years after when
I was in college I told one of my
professors I had a tumor so I could get
out of a class to go on I make
[Music]
my biggest slice that I like president
Donald Trump I haven't come out to a lot
of my family about being clear and so I
was not hurt
I've been lying about that for a long
time I love you I told a boyfriend that
I love him
or nine months my [ __ ] lie
never been a to day this is gonna sound
like a lie but I really don't like to
lie I just don't believe in it I think
if you do something that you should take
responsibility for your actions
so I mean white lies happen I don't
think I really like about anything big
that I can remember I'm a virgin it's
not true when I was in like eighth grade
I told my best friend that I had an
adopted sister who lived in my parents
closet and he like actually believed me
like if this went on for about four
months he like asked me like about how
my sister was her name was like Sylvia
or something my biggest lie ever told oh
okay I got one um when I was in high
school actually broke my mom's
windshield by punching it and I said a
big rock came flying out of the bushes
and hit it and she believed it when I
was a kid my older brother snuck out of
the house to go skateboarding with his
friends when he was grounded and he
ended up breaking his elbow when he was
skating and he I don't know how but he
climbed back in the window upstairs
second-story and he called me upstairs
he said hey dude I broke my arm or
something he was all messed up he said
let's pretend like we're wrestling right
now and then we'll tell mom that I fell
off the bed or something and I'm like
okay for sure so I jumped off the bed
and like made a big thud and he starts
crying like a baby
oh my arm until we were like 35 my mom
thought she broke his elbow wrestling on
the bed which doesn't
probably trying to lie that I didn't
make my bed one page of my mom and I had
the sheets under it all messed up and I
just fold at the top over and made it
really bad ah the car tease
biggest lie in grade school I told the
people I was from Hawaii for well we
moved so they still think I'm from
Hawaii um my freshman year at college I
told people I wasn't sneaking into my
boyfriend's apartment when we got
married the first meal she made me I I
told her it was really good but it was
like one of the worst things I've ever
eaten she did now she it does now she's
not bad for a little bit for a while in
fifth grade I told everyone I had
started my period but I had no idea I
once told somebody that I was a musician
on tour and that was she was a girl that
was trying to impress her
and she was impressed yeah yeah yeah Ali
knew her for about a week yeah apply if
she believes it if she sees it she's
gonna be like he's not a musician so
hope this doesn't fall into her hands
yeah
in middle school I got suspended very
ten days and I didn't tell my mom and
for ten days my mom would take me to
school and drop me off and I would walk
to the park behind it was
and I just I did that for ten days you
never found out never never
you